people email us um questions and we try
to answer them
okay on helpful advice with bobby kalila
michael bisping and rebecca
uh hey friends my fiance and i are about
to have a baby she's only two months
along but it seems so close to nine
months
my uh my problem is i can't get her to
quit smoking cigarettes as soon as i
found out she was pregnant i quit
because i want what's best for our baby
and our family how can i try to convince
her to quit without making her think
she's against what's best for our family
i know she loves me and i know she'll
love our baby but i know she can love
herself me and our baby so much more if
she does things
she knows she needs to do thanks love
you guys
how does he convince his fiance to quit
smoking for the baby
are you convinced how do you convince
rebecca well well i mean it's pretty
obvious number one
cigarettes kill you they'll kill the
mother they could kill the baby they're
doing harm
that's for damn sure rebecca this is why
i push this over to you listen there's
one thing she knows about it's babies
and drinking while he's pregnant yeah
while pregnant eating whatever kind of
foods whilst pregnant i was like
this is your [ __ ] wheelhouse all
right let's let's okay rebecca so
i'm just gonna say let's suppose i'm
your friend where you you and i have
i go to orange county okay you and i
having brunch
right you and i are having brunch right
and i'm talking calella's pregnant
so i'm gonna go so rebecca kalila
you know she's two months pregnant as
you know well what about i'm weird
i'm right next to you in front of you
and i'm just smoking and you see that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's smoking she's pregnant
what would you say
i would say i'm completely
non-confrontational yeah
right you'd be like oh my god when you
left i'd be like oh my god
oh yeah
i like it constantly when she's pregnant
that's disgusting and then whenever you
come up like go hey
i'm so bad like that yeah but but yeah i
know she's really really damaging the
health of her unborn baby that
baby could be born with a low birth rate
i know that much if you
smoke heavily whilst pregnant yeah
sorry but low birth weight oh wait yeah
yes i might have said right i mean
right yeah that's not low birth weight i
just don't think that it would be
it's not the healthy it's not like
taking vitamins it's not like vitamins
would be good right
well vitamins are great yeah yeah yeah
you know it's not as bad as heroin
if it was heroin i would be like hey man
put the needle down yeah yeah right now
i feel like heroin is better
than nicotine you think so yeah well all
right no not heroin because the baby
would
yeah yeah they have to withdraw yeah
withdrawals yeah yeah
maybe crack they're not not not that's
great
let's get off the class babies you know
yeah i just think you know what i would
do i would just like to sit down with
her and go
listen i don't care what you do with
your body i do right
but if you choose to smoke smoke but
you have our baby inside you can you
please wait until you have the baby
or at least be drunk you
i would say you know what i mean yeah
yeah something like that yeah stop being
a selfish [ __ ] yeah that's a
raisin baby inside your stomach you
should know better
is that a real question that is a real
question that's a real question we get
so many weird ones
don't be a selfish [ __ ] you have a baby
inside yourself here we go there we go
that's the and that's the answer don't
be a self-esteem don't be a selfish
[ __ ] do we have another one because
that's a given
yeah hello my name is ethan i've been
single for six years uh-oh there's been
dates
but sex uh there's been dates and sex
but zero intimacy
recently started dating a young lady and
i cannot keep it up during sex long
enough for me to finish
she gets off and i'm going soft